من ركبنا ابو محمد اغنيه ومشاهد ارتبطت
بذاكره السعوديين طوال 18 عاما مضت ثنائيه
القصب والسدحان تعود في طاش العوده بعد 11
عاما من الغياب
الحافظ ترحيب وترقب بين اوساط السعوديين
بهذه العوده للمسلسل الذي بقي خالدا في
ذاكره السعوديين لعقود
ضعي رقمك عند الاخوان
ويصير خير ان شاء الله افكار جريئه طرحها
المسلسل الشهير في مواسمه السابقه الا ان
التساؤلات تدور حول هذه النسخه من طاش
الفنان السعودي ناصر القصبي اكد ان طاش
العوده سيشهد استرجاعا لبعض الشخصيات
والافكار التي طرحت سابقا
تركترات اللي عندنا يعني ايضا بدينا نرجع
بعضها مش كلها حاولنا ايضا انه يكون اغلب
الممثلين اللي اللي
ساهموا معنا في طاش للاسف في الافكار هي
اللي تحدد انت وين تتحرك وتختار مين وايضا
بعد انقطاع
والانقطاع طويل يعني اكثر من عشر سنوات
ما التقينا في عمل
فالناس حتكون مبسوطه انها تشوف اثنين
ارتبطوا معهم في فتره من الفترات انهم لما
يرجعون شو بيقدمون يعني عشرون حلقه فقط
عمر طاش العوده تاتي في ظل تغييرات كبيره
في صناعه الدراما السعوديه والتغييرات
الاكبر في ثقافه المجتمع وقضاياه التي لم
تعد كما كانت عليه